هناك صور وصلتنا الان تظهر الدخان يتصاعد
من احدى محطات الوقود التي تم استهدافها
من الجانب اللبناني طبعا
من خلال اطلاقهم جهه غير معروفه حتى الان
البعض يشير الى مجموعات فلسطينيه حزب الله
طبعا خرج بحسب المصادر الاسرائيليه
والتصريحات الاسرائيليه والاعلام
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن اذننا حزب الله يهدد
باستهداف حيفا ان كان هناك رد فعل مبالغ
اسرائيل طبعا كما شاهدت ونشاهد الان على
هذه الصور طبعا محطه وقود تم استهدافها
والنيران تتصاعد منها كان مراسل العربيه
يتحدث ايضا بالرغم من اعتراض اسرائيل عدد
من الصواريخ الا ان هناك منشاه في نهاريا
وهي على الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه تم
استهدافها وايضا هناك اصابه لاحد المستوط